[Music]
you've seen the title so you know this
is leading to a certain fractal and
actually it's an infinite family of
fractals
and yeah it'll be one of those
mind-bogglingly intricate shapes that
has infinite detail no matter how far
you zoom in but this is not really a
video about generating some pretty
picture for us to gawk at well okay
maybe that's part of it but the real
story here has a much more pragmatic
starting point than the story behind a
lot of other fractals
and more than that the final images that
we get to will become a lot more
meaningful if we make an effort to
understand why given what they represent
they kind of have to look as complicated
as they do and what this complexity
reflects about an algorithm that is used
all over the place in engineering
the starting point here will be to
assume that you have some kind of
polynomial and that you want to know
when it equals zero so for the one
graphed here you can visually see
there's three different places where it
crosses the x-axis and you can kind of
eyeball what those values might be we'd
call those the roots of the polynomial
but how do you actually compute them
exactly
now this is the kind of question where
if you're already bought into math maybe
it's interesting enough in its own right
to move forward but if you just pull
someone on the street aside and ask them
this i mean they're already falling
asleep because who cares
but the thing is this kind of question
comes up all the time in engineering
where i'm personally most familiar with
equations like this popping up is in the
setting of computer graphics where
polynomials are just littered all over
the place so it's not uncommon that when
you're figuring out how a given pixel
should be colored that somehow involves
solving an equation that uses these
polynomials
here let me give you one fun example
when a computer renders text on the
screen those fonts are typically not
defined using pixel values they're
defined as a bunch of polynomial curves
where they're known in the business as
bezier curves
and any of you who've messed around with
vector graphics maybe in some design
software would be well familiar with
these kinds of curves
but to actually display one of them on
the screen you need a way to tell each
one of the pixels of your screen whether
it should be colored in or not these
curves can be displayed either with some
kind of stroke width or if they enclose
a region some kind of fill for that
region
but if you step back and you really
think about it it's an interesting
puzzle to figure out how each one of the
pixels knows whether it should be
colored in or not just based on the pure
mathematical curve
i mean take the case of stroke width
this comes down to understanding how far
away a given pixel is from this pure
mathematical curve which itself is some
platonic ideal it has zero width
you would think of it as a parametric
curve that has some parameter t
now one thing that you could do to
figure out this distance is to compute
the distance between your pixel and a
bunch of sample points on that curve and
then figure out the smallest
but that's both inefficient and
imprecise better is to get a little
mathematical and acknowledge that this
distance to the curve at all the
possible points is itself some smooth
function of the parameter
and as it happens the square of that
distance will itself be a polynomial
which makes it pretty nice to deal with
and if this were meant to be a full
lesson on rendering vector graphics we
could expand all that out and embrace
the mess but right now the only salient
point that i want to highlight is that
in principle this function whose minimum
you want to know is some polynomial
finding this minimum and hence
determining how close the pixel is to
the curve and whether it should get
filled in is now just a classic calculus
problem
what you do is figure out the slope of
this function graph which is to say its
derivative again some polynomial
and you ask when does that equal zero
so to actually carry out this seemingly
simple task of just displaying a curve
wouldn't it be nice if you had a
systematic and general way to figure out
when a given polynomial equals zero
of course we could draw a hundred other
examples from a hundred other
disciplines i just want you to keep in
mind that as we seek the roots of
polynomials even though we always
display it in a way that's cleanly
abstracted away from the messiness of
any real world problem the task is
hardly just an academic one
but again ask yourself how do you
actually compute one of those roots
if whatever problem you're working on
leads you to a quadratic function then
happy days you can use the quadratic
formula that we all know and love
and as a fun side note by the way again
relevant to root finding and computer
graphics i once had a pixar engineer
give me the estimate that considering
how many lights were used in some of the
scenes for the movie coco and given the
nature of some of these per-pixel
calculations when polynomially defined
things like spheres are involved the
quadratic formula was easily used
multiple trillions of times in the
production of that film
now when your problem leads you to a
higher order polynomial things start to
get trickier for cubic polynomials there
is also a formula which mathologer has
done a wonderful video on there's even a
quartic formula something that solves
degree 4 polynomials although honestly
that one is such a god-awful nightmare
of a formula that essentially no one
actually uses it in practice
but after that and i find this one of
the most fascinating results in all of
math you cannot have an analogous
formula to solve polynomials that have a
degree five or more
more specifically for a pretty extensive
set of standard functions you can prove
that there is no possible way that you
can combine those functions together
that allows you to plug in the
coefficients of a quintic polynomial and
always get out a root
this is known as the unsolvability of
the quintic which is a whole other can
of worms we can hopefully get into it
some other time but in practice it kind
of doesn't matter because we have
algorithms to approximate solutions to
these kinds of equations with whatever
level of precision you want
a common one and the main topic for you
and me today is newton's method and yes
this is what will lead us to the
fractals but i want you to pay attention
to just how innocent and benign the
whole procedure seems at first
the algorithm begins with a random guess
let's call it x naught
almost certainly the output of your
polynomial at x naught is not zero so
you haven't found a solution it's some
other value visible as the height of
this graph at that point so to improve
the guess the idea is to ask when does a
linear approximation to the function
around that value equal zero
in other words if you were to draw a
tangent line to the graph at this point
when does that tangent line cross the
x-axis
now assuming this tangent line is a
decent approximation of the function in
the loose vicinity of some true root the
place where this approximation equals
zero should take you closer to that true
root
and as long as you're able to take a
derivative of this function and with
polynomials you'll always be able to do
that you can concretely compute the
slope of this line
so here's where the active viewers among
you might want to pause and ask how do
you figure out the difference between
the current guess and the improved guess
what is the size of this step
one way to think of it is to consider
the fact that the slope of this tangent
line its rise over run looks like the
height of this graph divided by the
length of that step
but on the other hand of course the
slope of the tangent line is the
derivative of the polynomial at that
point
if we kind of rearrange this equation
here this gives you a super concrete way
that you can compute that step size
so the next guess which we might call x1
is the previous guess adjusted by this
step size
and after that you can just repeat the
process you compute the value of this
function and the slope at this new guess
which gives you a new linear
approximation and then you make the next
guess x2 wherever that tangent line
crosses the x-axis
and then apply the same calculation to
x2 and this gives you x3 and before too
long you find yourself extremely close
to a true root pretty much as close as
you could ever want to be
it's always worth gut checking that a
formula actually makes sense and in this
case hopefully it does if p of x is
large meaning the graph is really high
you need to take a bigger step to get
down to a root
but if p prime of x is also large
meaning the graph is quite steep you
should maybe ease off on just how big
you make that step
as the name suggests this was a method
that newton used to solve polynomial
expressions but he sort of made it look
a lot more complicated than it needed to
be and a fellow named joseph rafson
published a much simpler version more
like what you and i are looking at now
so you also often hear this algorithm
called the newton-raphson method
these days it's a common topic in
calculus classes one nice little
exercise to try to get a feel for it by
the way is to try using this method to
approximate square roots by hand
but what most calculus students don't
see which is unfortunate is just how
deep things can get when you let
yourself play around with this seemingly
simple procedure and start kind of
picking at some of its scabs
you see while newton's method works
great if you start near a root where it
converges really quickly if your initial
guess is far from a root it can have a
couple foibles
for example let's take the function we
were just looking at but shifted upward
and play the same game with the same
initial guess
notice how the sequence of new guesses
that we're getting kind of bounces
around the local minimum of this
function sitting above the x-axis
and this should kind of make sense i
mean a linear approximation of the
function around these values all the way
to the right is pretty much entirely
unrelated to the nature of the function
around the one true root that it has off
to the left so they're sort of giving
you no useful information about that
true root it's only when this process
just happens to throw the new guess off
far enough to the left by chance that
the sequence of new guesses does
anything productive and actually
approaches that true root
where things get especially interesting
is if we ask about finding roots in the
complex plane
even if a polynomial like the one shown
here has only a single real number root
you'll always be able to factor this
polynomial into five terms like this if
you allow these roots to potentially be
complex numbers this is the famous
fundamental theorem of algebra now in
the happy go lucky land of functions
with real number inputs and real number
outputs where you can picture the
association between inputs and outputs
as a graph newton's method has this
really nice visual meaning with tangent
lines and intersecting the x-axis but if
you want to allow these inputs to be any
complex number which means our
corresponding outputs might also be any
complex number you can't think about
tangent lines and graphs anymore
but the formula doesn't really care how
you visualize it you can still play the
same game starting with a random guess
and evaluating the polynomial at this
point as well as its derivative
then using this update rule to generate
a new guess and hopefully that new guess
is closer to the true root
but i do want to be clear even if we
can't visualize these steps with a
tangent line it really is the same logic
we're figuring out where a linear
approximation of the function around
your guess would equal zero and then you
use that zero of the linear
approximation as your next guess
it's not like we're blindly applying the
rule to a new context with no reason to
expect it to work
and indeed with at least the one i'm
showing here after a few iterations you
can see that we land on a value whose
corresponding output is essentially zero
now here's the fun part let's apply this
idea to many different possible initial
guesses
for reference i'll put up the five true
roots of this particular polynomial in
the complex plane
with each iteration each one of our
little dots takes some step based on
newton's method
most of the dots will quickly converge
to one of the five true roots but there
are some noticeable stragglers which
seem to spend a while bouncing around
in particular notice how the ones that
are trapped on the positive real number
line well they look a little bit lost
and this is exactly what we already saw
before for the same polynomial when we
were looking at the real number case
with its graph
now what i'm going to do is color each
one of these dots based on which of
those five roots it ended up closest to
and then we'll kind of roll back the
clock so that every dot goes back to
where it started
now as i've done it here this isn't
quite enough resolution to get the full
story so let me show you what it would
look like if we started with an even
finer grid of initial guesses and played
the same game applying newton's method a
whole bunch of times letting each route
march forward
coloring each dot based on what root it
lands on then rolling back the clock to
see where it originally came from
but even this isn't really a high enough
resolution to appreciate the pattern if
we did this process for every single
pixel on the plane here's what you would
get
and at this level of detail the color
scheme is a little jarring to my eye at
least so let me calm it down a little
really whatever resolution i try to use
to show this to you here could never
possibly be enough because the finer
details of the shape we get go on with
endless complexity
[Music]
but take a moment to think about what
this is actually saying
it means that there are regions in the
complex plane where if you slightly
adjust that seed value you know you just
kind of bump it to the side by 1 1
millionth or 1 1 trillionth it can
completely change which of the 5 true
roots it ends up landing on
we saw some foreshadowing of this kind
of chaos with the real graph and the
problematic guess shown earlier but
picturing all of this in the complex
plane really shines a light on just how
unpredictable this kind of root finding
algorithm can be and how there are whole
swaths of initial values where the sort
of unpredictability will take place
now if i grab one of these roots and
change it around meaning that we're
using a different polynomial for the
process you can see how the resulting
fractal pattern changes
and notice for example how the regions
around a given root always have the same
color since those are the points that
are close enough to the root where this
linear approximation scheme works as a
way of finding that root with no problem
all of the chaos seems to be happening
at the boundaries between the regions
remember that
and it seems like no matter where i
place these roots those fractal
boundaries are always there it clearly
wasn't just some one-off for the
polynomial we happen to start with it
seems to be a general fact for any given
polynomial
another facet we can tweak here just to
better illustrate what's going on is how
many steps of newton's method we're
using
for example if i had the computer just
take zero steps meaning it just colors
each point of the plane based on
whatever route it's already closest to
this is what we'd get and this kind of
diagram actually has a special name it's
called a voronoi diagram
and if we let each point of the plane
take a single step of newton's method
and then color it based on what root
that single step result is closest to
here's what we would get
similarly if we allow for two steps we
get a slightly more intricate pattern
and so on and so on where the more steps
you allow the more intricate an image
you get bringing us closer to the
original fractal and this is important
keep in mind that the true shape we're
studying here is not any one of these
it's the limit as we allow for an
arbitrarily large number of iterations
at this point there are so many
questions we might ask like maybe you
want to try this out with some other
polynomials see how general it is or
maybe you want to dig deeper into what
dynamics are exactly possible with these
iterated points or see if there's
connections with some other pieces of
math that have a similar theme
but i think the most pertinent question
should be something like what is going
on here
i mean all we're doing here is
repeatedly solving linear approximations
why would that produce something that's
so endlessly complicated it almost feels
like the underlying rule here just
shouldn't carry enough information to
actually produce an image like this
and before seeing this don't you think a
reasonable initial guess might have been
that each seed value simply tends
towards whichever route it's closest to
and in that case you know if you colored
each point based on the root it lands on
and move it back to the original
position the final image would look like
one of these voronoi diagrams with
straight-line boundaries
and since i referenced earlier the
unsolvability of the quintic maybe you
would wonder if the complexity here has
anything to do with that that would be
cool but they're essentially unrelated
ideas in fact using only degree 5
polynomials so far might have been a
little misleading watch what happens if
we play the same game but with a cubic
polynomial with three roots somewhere in
the complex plane
notice how again while most points
nestle into a root some of them are kind
of flying all over the place more
chaotically
in fact those ones are the most
noticeable ones in an animation like
this with the ones going towards the
roots just quietly nestled in in their
ending points
and again if we stopped this at some
number of iterations and we colored all
the points based on what root they're
closest to and roll back the clock the
relevant picture for all possible
starting points forms this fractal
pattern with infinite detail
however quadratic polynomials with only
two roots are different in that case
each seed value does simply tend towards
whichever root it's closest to the way
that you might expect
there is a little bit of meandering
behavior from all the points that are an
equal distance from each root it's kind
of like they're not able to decide which
one to go to but that's just a single
line of points and when we play the game
of coloring the diagram we end up with
is decidedly more
boring so something new seems to happen
when you jump from two to three and the
question is what exactly
and if you had asked me a month ago i
probably would have shrugged and just
said you know math is what it is
sometimes the answers look simple
sometimes not it's not always clear what
it would mean to ask why in a setting
like this
but i would have been wrong there
actually is a reason that we can give
for why this image has to look as
complicated as it does
you see there's a very peculiar property
that we can prove this diagram must have
focus your attention on just one of the
colored regions say this blue one in
other words the set of all points that
eventually tend towards just one
particular root of the polynomial
now consider the boundary of that region
which for the example shown on screen
has this kind of nice three-fold
symmetry
what's surprising is that if you look at
any other color and consider its
boundary you get precisely the same set
now when i say the word boundary you
probably have an intuitive sense of what
it means but mathematicians have a
pretty clever way to formalize it and
this makes it easier to reason about in
the context of more wild sets like our
fractal
we say that a point is on the boundary
of a set if when you draw a small circle
centered at that point no matter how
small it will always contain points that
are both inside that set and outside
so if you have a point that's on the
interior a small enough circle would
eventually only contain points inside
the set and for a point on the exterior
a small enough circle contains no points
of the set at all but when it's on the
boundary what it means to be on the
boundary is that your tiny tiny circles
will always contain both
so looking back at our property one way
to read it is to say that if you draw a
circle no matter how small that circle
it either contains all of the colors
which happens when this shared boundary
of the colors is inside that circle
or it contains just one color and this
happens when it's in the interior of one
of the regions
in particular what this implies is you
should never be able to find a circle
that contains just two of the colors
since that would require that you have
points on the boundary between two
regions but not all of them
and before explaining where this fact
actually comes from it's fun to try just
wrapping your mind around it a little
bit you could imagine presenting this to
someone as a kind of art puzzle
completely out of context never
mentioning newton's method or anything
like that where you say that the
challenge is to construct a picture with
at least three colors maybe we say red
green and blue so that the boundary of
one color is the boundary of all of them
so if you started with something simple
like this that clearly doesn't work
because we have this whole line of
points that are on the boundary of green
and red but not touching any blue and
likewise you have these other lines of
disallowed points
so to correct that you might go and add
some blue blobs along the boundary and
then likewise add some green blobs
between the red and blue and some red
blobs between the green and blue
but of course now the boundary of those
blobs are a problem for example touching
just blue and red but no green
so maybe you go and you try to add even
smaller blobs with the relevant third
color around those smaller boundaries to
help try to correct
and likewise you have to do this for
every one of the blobs that you
initially added
but then all the boundaries of those
tiny blobs are problems of their own and
you would have to somehow keep doing
this process forever
and if you look at newton's fractal
itself this sort of blobs on blobs on
blob's pattern seems to be exactly what
it's doing
the main thing i want you to notice is
how this property implies you could
never have a boundary which is smooth or
even partially smooth on some small
segment since any smooth segment would
only be touching two colors
instead the boundary has to consist
entirely of sharp corners so to speak
so if you believe the property it
explains why the boundary remains rough
no matter how far you zoom in and for
those of you who are familiar with the
concept of fractal dimension you can
measure the dimension of the particular
boundary i'm showing you right now to be
around 1.44
considering what our colors actually
represent remember this isn't just a
picture for pictures sake think about
what the property is really telling us
it says that if you're near a sensitive
point where some of the seed values go
to one root but other seed values nearby
would go to another root then in fact
every possible route has to be
accessible from within that small
neighborhood for any tiny little circle
that you draw either all of the points
in that circle tend to just one root or
they tend to all of the roots but
there's never going to be anything in
between just tending to a subset of the
roots
for a little intuition i found it
enlightening to simply watch a cluster
like the one on screen undergo this
process
it starts off mostly sticking together
but at one iteration they all kind of
explode outward and after that it feels
a lot more reasonable that any root is
up for grabs
and keep in mind i'm just showing you
finitely many points but in principle
you would want to think about what
happens to all uncountably infinitely
many points inside some small disk
this property also kind of explains why
it's okay for things to look normal in
the case of quadratic polynomials with
just two roots because there a smooth
boundary is fine there's only two colors
to touch anyway
to be clear it doesn't guarantee that
the quadratic case would have a smooth
boundary it is perfectly possible to
have a fractal boundary between two
colors it just looks like our newton's
method diagram is not doing anything
more complicated than it needs to
under the constraint of this strange
boundary condition
but of course all of this simply raises
the question of why this bizarre
boundary property would have to be true
in the first place where does it even
come from for that i'd like to tell you
about a field of math which studies this
kind of question it's called holomorphic
dynamics and i think we've covered
enough ground today and there's
certainly enough left to tell so it
makes sense to pull that out as a
separate video
to close things off here there is
something sort of funny to me about the
fact that we call this newton's fractal
despite the fact that newton had no clue
about any of this and could never have
possibly played with these images the
way that you and i can with modern
technology and it happens a lot through
math that people's names get attached to
things well beyond what they could have
dreamed of hamiltonians are central to
quantum mechanics despite hamilton
knowing nothing about quantum mechanics
fourier himself never once computed a
fast fourier transform the list goes on
but this over extension of nomenclature
carries with it what i think is an
inspiring point
it reflects how even the simple ideas
ones that could be discovered centuries
ago often hold within them some new
angle or a new domain of relevance they
can sit waiting to be discovered
hundreds of years later
it's not just that newton had no idea
about newton's fractal there are
probably many other facts about newton's
method or about all sorts of math that
may seem like old news that come from
questions that no one has thought to ask
yet questions that are just sitting
there waiting for someone like you to
ask them
for example if you were to ask about
whether this process we've been talking
about today ever gets trapped in a cycle
it leads you to a surprising connection
with the mandelbrot set and we'll talk a
bit about that in the next part
at the time that i'm posting this that
second part by the way is available as
an early release to patrons i always
like to give new content a little bit of
time there to gather feedback and catch
errors the finalized version should be
out shortly
and on the topic of patrons i do just
want to say a quick thanks to everyone
whose name is on the screen i know that
in recent history new videos have been a
little slow coming part of this has to
do with other projects that have been in
the works things i'm proud of by the way
things like the summer of math
exposition which was a surprising amount
of work to be honest but so worth it
given the outcome i will be talking all
about that and announcing winners very
shortly so stay tuned i just want you to
know that the plan for the foreseeable
future is definitely to shift gears more
wholeheartedly back to making new videos
and more than anything i want to say
thanks for your continued support even
during times of trying a few new things
it means a lot to me it's what keeps the
channel going and i'll do my best to
make the new lessons in the pipeline
live up to your vote of confidence there
[Music]
you